saleem Torah Valley is on the alert
ready to spring into action in an
emergency with tens of thousands of
football fans attending euro 2016
matches to cheer on their national teams
France is on high alert Tora Valley is
one of hundreds of security guards at
the stud to force silly study what
they'll do la I try to recognize in
advance which people might pose a threat
I pass on the information using this
microphone and headphone it's then
relayed to stadium security civil y el
estado still hooligans have managed to
smuggle fireworks into the stadiums and
there have been severe clashes both
before and after the matches it's just
not possible for torah bally and his
colleagues to have everything under
control I was worried earlier a bus full
of Germans arrived and they were
actually drinking beer at seven in the
morning he says he and his colleagues
have to react immediately to keep
situations from escalating and he knows
what he's talking about his
attentiveness prevented a massacre he
drives around the stud to France with us
to entrance el where he was posted on
November the 13th of last year for the
match between France and Germany a young
man tried to get into the stadium
through this gate without a ticket his
behavior attracted my attention he was
different from other spectators he had a
goal he was in a hurry he said I must
get in the person who has my ticket is
inside
tura bally instinctively blocked the
man's way and made sure his colleagues
didn't let him through either what he
couldn't know was that the man belonged
to a suicide commando just moments later
a bomb exploded in front of the stadium
killing a passerby dizzy Marshall oculus
there was blood everywhere and I didn't
have any gloves I still see the strips
of flesh on the legs of the injured
person each time there's an attack
somewhere I see all the panic and
sadness at first tura Bally didn't want
to work during football games again but
now the security guard himself a
football fan is back at the stadium and
germany is playing again this time
against Poland many of the fans who've
come to Paris despite the terrorism
threat have pushed aside any fears and a
blindly trusting the security personnel
they started early with a security check
so it's all fine I'm not scared they've
got everything under control police have
cordoned off areas around stadiums and
fanzones but it's mainly private
companies that carry out the controls at
the stadium entrances their staff
usually protect buildings against
break-ins and experts say they have no
training for mass sporting events for
cost reasons the companies often hire
immigrants and allegedly did not conduct
proper background checks pollution is a
problem that's relatively new is the
radicalization of private security staff
who turn to Islamic extremism and are
obviously in very sensitive positions
this'll should be we estimate there are
dozens and i would say several hundred
security officers who are radical
Islamists can they be fired no so it's
legally very complicated Torah Bali is
critical of the sector's employment
practices he thinks staff assigned to
major public events should be very
carefully
what is it solid elastically dizzy to
our one good football if I work in
security then I have to be a role model
I can't instruct other people on how to
behave if I'm creating a much bigger
problem in my private life these are the
problem that we predict what if it were
up to Torah Bali all security personnel
would have emergency services training
during the attack in November the 43
year old was one of the few people
present who knew what to do since he's
had first aid training now Celine Torah
Bally has been honored for his efforts
at the highest level she did a dead look
at this photo I'm with president
hollande he said I was an example for
the whole profession Torah ballys wife
bebe is proud that her husband has
become a role model in France but now
during euro 2016 she's very aware of the
danger he puts himself in each day it
does make me afraid it seems others are
afraid to fewer people are visiting the
fan zones than in past European
Championships the euphoria is rather
subdued and Celine Torah Valley will
continue to be on the lookout for
potential danger